hello remember me
no I'm not Frankenstein everyone's
always mixing me up but the scientist
who created me Victor Frankenstein but
he never bothered to give me a name in
fact he never cared much for me I asked
him for one thing a female companion a
bride but he refused he feared she and I
would create a new race that would drive
humans to extinction he called me a
demon a monster in the 21st century
there are many potential dr.
Frankenstein's and they might create
their own monsters or with today's
scientists call existential risks in the
past humans didn't have to worry about
science that could end humanity itself
then came July 16 1945 when people
detonated the first atom bomb some
scientists feared that this test might
set off a chain reaction that would
ignite the atmosphere today we know that
there was no way this could have
happened but that was the first
human-made existential risk and from it
grew a weapons stockpile that brought a
real dire threat nuclear holocaust
there are now three academic centers
dedicated studying existential risks the
researchers there argue that there are
plenty of new existential risks on the
horizon that could be brought about
either through error war terror new
potent viruses made in the lab could
escape and kill billions of people
artificial intelligence
tasks to say solving a mathematical
problem could pursue that task so
single-mindedly
that along the way it creates an
environment fatal to humans simply
because it hasn't been programmed to
recognize this an army of nanobots tiny
self-replicating robots could destroy
the biosphere some think these scenarios
are too unlikely to deserve study that
humans should concentrate on compat and
climate change and avoiding nuclear war
but others argue that this is a new
category of risk and the old approaches
of trial and error won't work when it
comes to averting the end of the world
so new strategies are needed but for the
moment most scientists are still stuck
on the first part of the work coming up
with scenarios that present humanity
with existential risks it's the kind of
work where scientists have few examples
except one towering figure of course my
real creator Mary Shelley
[Music]
you